what did you see just
you know i came from the soviet union
what did you
maybe feel
that's
right and good about communism about the
vision of communism do you remember like
i think the
biggest impetus and me believing in
communism was that
com the communists when when
just before hitler took over
the communists were
the only force
in germany that fought the nazis
in the streets
and that's
a historic truth yes and and communists
were
hunted down by the nazis
killed
uh put in concentration camps
and
so what we knew
when what we were taught and i think
that was a huge unforced era by the
western countries particularly the
united states that there were ex-nazis
in the government in west germany
yeah and uh the most famous one was uh
reinhard galen who was in charge was the
general in charge of uh
[Music]
the
intelligence on the eastern front under
hitler
and when
the
uh the allied won the war
it was decided that galen was too
important uh with his knowledge of the
his and his organization was too
important to uh
to
not use so he was co-opted by the cia
and eventually wound up
being the head of the bundesliga the cia
of west germany
that gave us
us when i say us you know the east
german
party a huge propaganda victory
i wanted to because his um the emotional
aspect of this was as follows
when we uh we were in uh
juniors in high school
uh and in those in those days uh
when you
you were only allowed to go to high
school if you were in the top 10 of
students okay so this was going to be
the
next set of ruling elite in the country
we were sent
we were required to visit a
concentration camp
and
if you know what what we as 17 year olds
were made to look at
it was gut-wrenching
how can men do something like that to
men
piles of corpses
uh
lamp shades made out of human skin
because
uh they
that skin had tattoos on them and if
shrunken had some heads like the size of
my fist
and i mean the girls all cried
and it would have made a huge impression
and that was the
that was the nazis and then yes the
communists i mean the unity fighters
they were the good guys of course you
know in in hindsight if the communists
had come to power it would have been
just the other way around as we know
uh given the example of stalin and mao
right so but we didn't know that
right
from the russian soviet perspective uh
the communist regime
banded together
to
win the great patriotic war and that was
the the second one you know the big
brother the soviet union
uh i mean when when i was approached by
the kgb that was like oh i felt so
honored
you